you know what's nice i went backstage to
say hi uh before the show and and your
mom was there and you introduced me and
uh i realized i always think it's nice
when people bring their family along
with them to show biz occasions or
events i think it's kind of cool yeah
it's kind of fun who did you bring who
did you you brought some family member
to the you were nominated for a golden
globe and you brought who did you bring
i brought my mom i brought i brought
that same lady and we sat that same lady
that same one the same mom and she she
uh we sat at a table next to brad pitt
and angeline jolie whoa which was like
the ultimate thing to bring your mom to
sure because she
never drinks and there was this giant
bottle of moe champagne because they
were sponsoring the event
and so she had a lot of champagne
and she was talking to them about their
kids
which was really interesting
and funny so your mom was getting pretty
loose she was getting pretty loose and
she was like
now you guys must be so tired
you two
and then she's leaning over me to
angelina jolie and i'm like
and angelina's like yeah you know all
these kids my mom's like now how old is
the old they grow up so fast you're
gonna it flies it flies
i was like oh boy oh
boy so she was really getting into it it
was fun it was pretty fun yeah have you
who else have you taken to an event have
you ever taken like a grandma or anybody
oh grandma yeah that was last week at
the today show they came in we did the
today show for crazy stupid lovin and uh
they came down and they said uh your
grandmother's here
can she come back into your dressing
room and i was like what is my grandma
doing here oh she wasn't even invited no
she just it's like grandma's here i was
like oh okay okay
nene i call her nanny and she uh she
came into my dressing room she was like
now emily my name my real name is emily
it was taken at the screen actually she
said uh emily
i do you remember when you were 10 and
you were waiting outside the today
showing you had a sign and ann curry
said hi to you and you're so excited
i was like yeah i remember i remember
please don't tell her that and she said
oh i already did she let me in
so great she is so nice still
oh boy and then i met matt lauer and
he's like your grandma told me so much
about you earlier it's great let's get
started so a bed wetter from an early
age
that's sort of my nightmare scenario
whenever my parents start to creep into
my show but i love them but whenever
they start to come into the showbiz life
yeah i think i think of all the stuff
they could say about me they might all
the operations
uh
so you're so busy right now you've got
so many movies go you have crazy stupid
love okay with an incredible steve
carell ryan gosling i mean this must be
a lot of fun to make this film yeah it
was it was not too shabby that was
pretty mind-blowing and the help opens
in august is that yeah august 10th wow
so that's a pretty
close proximity to each other
[Laughter]
now i hope there's a long scene in that
movie where all the characters talk
about how much they'd like to do me
there obviously is it's 1963 jackson
mississippi but it's all coney all the
time
good because that'll make up for that in
the future there'll be a guy who we all
want to do
you're not going with that ginger junk
andy don't let it
i don't want it to catch on
sorry it's too late uh well crazy stupid
love opens friday and the help opens
august 10th emma real thrill having you
on the show thank you
[Applause]